وعلى كل حال سالنا الناس في الاردن كيف
تواجهون التوتر والضغط النفسي في حياتكم
اليوميه لنتابع
[موسيقى]
والله انا بستغفر وبسبح اوقات بفتح القران
وبقرا قران بخفف شويه ضغط اللي في داخلي
واكثر من هيك ما بخف عني الضغط انا بواجهن
الضغط النفسي بالاستغفار فقط
وانت
[موسيقى]
بس وبصحى ميه بالميه والله في ايام رمضان
الفضيله هاي الواحد انه يعني يخلي ذكر
الله دائما على لسانه والاستغفار وهذا هاي
بتهدي لنفسه وبتخلي الواحد هيك
[موسيقى]
والله انا يعني اذا صار عنده ضغط نفسي
بسبح
بحاول ان انا اتناسى
عشان امشي الامور والله في اشياء كثير
الواحد ممكن يخلص من التوتر وبصير فيه من
ضمنها انه يلعب رياضه مثلا يكون مسجل في
نادي النادي هذا يكون يتابعه يعني يوم بعد
يوم زيك اللي يفرق طاقاته فيه لانه انت
لما تضلك تحوش طاقات تقبل طاقاتك بصير في
امراض وبيصير فيه انفجار
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات